تقدمت الحكومه الكويتيه برئاسه الشيخ احمد
نواف الاحمد الصباح استقالتها الى ولي
العهد الشيخ مشعل الاحمد الجابر الصباح
تاتي هذا الاستقاله غداه ازمه مع مجلس
الامه بسبب ما تعرف بالقوانين الشعبويه
ورفضها تقديم اي تعاهدات بهذا الشان اضافه
الى عدم استجابه البرلمان بسحب السجوى بين
لوزير الماليه والدوله لشؤون مجلس الوزراء
وهكذا من المفترض ان يتصدر جلسه البرلمان
غدا الثلاثاء يذكر ان استقاله الحكومات
تاتي بعد ثلاثه اشهر من تشكيلها
ينضم الينا من الكويت مدير مكتب الجزيره
سعد السعيد السعد المشهد يتكرر مره جديده
ما هي اصداء هذه الاستقاله وماذا بعدها
نعم فداء بالفعل بهذه الاستقاله تكون
البلاد قد عادت مره اخرى الى حاله من
الانسداد السياسي والى اذا اجازه لنا
التسميه ان نقول انهيار التعاون الذي كان
منشودا بين السلطتين التنفيذيه والتشريعيه
وخصوصا الامال التي عقدت خلال الاسابيع
الماضيه بعد انتخابات يعني جاءت باغلبيه
مريحه للشعب الكويتي وايضا تشكيل الحكومي
راه الشعب الكويتي كان متفائلا في
الاسابيع الماضيه هذا لانهيار اليوم حتى
الحكومه حين رفعت كتاب الاستقاله الى ولي
عهد البلاد الشيخ مشعل لاحمد الصباح يعني
جاءت بسبب بان او قالت بهذا الكتاب لما
التاليه العلاقه بين السلطتين التشريعيه
والتنفيذيه كيف بدات هذه كيف ساءت العلاقه
بين السلطتين التشريعيه والتنفيذيه في
الاسبوع الماضي وفي الجلسه الماضيه كان
هناك على جدول اعمال الجلسه الماضيه
التقرير للجنه الماليه الاقتصاديه
البرلمانيه هذا التغيير يتضمن مشاريع
تتعلق بسقاط او الغاء الفوائد على القروض
وكذلك شراء قروض المواطنين وايضا المعاشات
او زياده المعاشات التقاعديه وزياده
الرواتب للمواطنين هذا التقرير يبدو انه
يعني ارادت الحكومه اعادته مره اخرى الى
اللجنه المختصه اللجنه البرلمانيه
والماليه
لدراسته مع مع الهيئات المختصه والمتخصصه
ايضا من الجانب الحكومي غير ان اعضاء
البرلمان رفضوا بان يتم اا سحب هذا
التقرير ما ادى الى انسحاب الحكومه
بالمناسبه لا احد داخليه لمجلس الامه تسقط
اي جلسه او يسقط يسقط نصاب اي جلسه اذا لم
يكن هناك حضور حكومه وانسحاب الحكومه
الجلسه الماضيه اسقط تلك الجلسه وبالتالي
كان هذا استجاب للسلطه التنفي التشريعيه
ولنواب مجلس الامه حينما احد اعضاء مجلس
الامه به استجواب الى وزير الماليه من
سبعه محاور لحقته ايضا نائب همم جيران
بوشيري الى استجابه اخر لوزير الدوله الان
هناك سيناريوهات متعدده
ان السيناري ولا ارجع حتى الان ان يتم
قبول هذه الاستقاله وتصريف العاجل من
الامور وترك عدم عدم ترك او عدم تشكيل
حكومي جديد الى شهر مارس القادم انتظارا
لحكم محكمه دستوريه منتظر قد يسقط ايضا
حتى مجلس الامه او بطلان شكرا لك مدير
مكتب الجزيره سعد السعيدي كنت معنا من
الكويت